oh hi you know we're big fans of rock
band here at game life and when they
announced that rock band was going to
come to Sony's PSP we were all how's
that gonna work like is it gonna have a
crazy guitar fret controller thing like
guitar hero on the BS no no it's not
actually rock band unplugged coming very
soon to PSP is just going to use the
standard buttons at first glance
unplugged looks just like the rock band
you're used to the notes come down on
the screen and use the buttons to hit
them with the right timing and this
plays the individual parts of each song
that's the easy part now how do you play
all four instruments at once well each
part is divided up into short phrases if
you nail an entire phrase that
instrument will start playing itself for
a short while and you can move on to
another track the game will show you
which track to move to to keep your full
combo going occasionally in a song a
solo will pop up and you'll be locked
onto that instrument for the duration of
the solo if this all seems a bit
familiar to you you're probably thinking
about frequency and amplitude the
PlayStation 2 games that Harmonix made
for Sony before they created guitar hero
okay maybe the games look slightly
different but the gameplay feels a lot
like these classics I actually like it
better that wasn't the biggest amplitude
fan but rock band unplugged feels more
structured a little less chaotic rock
band unplugged has 40 different rock
songs including some that will appear
first on this PSP version like Jackson
5's ABC or tenacious d's rock your socks
and these songs will eventually appear
on rock band 2 for the console the rest
of the track list includes big hits from
previous rock band games including Buddy
Holly from Weezer or when you were young
from The Killers rock band unplugged
also features an in-game download store
where you can buy more tracks rock band
unplugged we release for the PSP on jun